and now a special look at marvel studios
original series
loki maybe loki wants to mix it up is
that possible
you can change hi
this variant is insubordinate
stubborn unpredictable
he's doing great you need the god of
mischief
but he's really arrogant i am loki
and i am burdened with glorious purpose
unbelievable wherever you go it's just
death destruction the literal
ends of worlds i know
original series streaming june 9th only
on disney plus
i know what this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
i am smart i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
[Music]
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
mommy i need your unique low-key
perspective
do i get a weapon yeah
you really believe in this loki variant
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
it is adorable that you think you could
possibly
manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
why never do it again
you